[Music]  a sweet surprise for some local students  powering through the summer school  governor steve siselek stopped by  dondero elementary here in vegas with  treats for the kids  we got to bring popsicles today which  everybody got a kick out of the kids  because it's so hot outside  they're excited behind me you can see  them all they want to be on tv so  they're all going to be watching tv  tonight to make sure they can pick  themselves up  well the governor was joined by  superintendent dr jesus jarrah among  others  he says this visit was important to  encourage the students to continue  working on their studies  during these next few months